what's the art in the art of programming
why why is there of the few words in the
title why is art one of them yeah well
that's that's what I wrote my Turing
lecture about and and so when people
talk about art it really I mean what the
word means is something that's not a
nature so when you have artificial
intelligence that that art comes from
the same root saying that this is
something that was created by by human
beings and then it's gotten a further
meaning often a fine art which has this
beauty to the to the mix and says you
know we have things that are
artistically done and and this means not
only done by humans but also done in a
way that's elegant and brings joy and
and has has I guess what Tolstoy pers
does the s key but anyway it it's that
part that that says that it's done well
as well as not only a different from
nature in general then alright is what
human beings are specifically good at
and when they say hey like artificial
intelligence well they're trying to
mimic human beings but there's an
element of fine art and beauty you are
well that's what I that's what I try to
also say that you can write a program
and make a work of art
you